I'm here in Beverly Hills California
canvassing for Bernie Sanders this is a
swing state it's gonna be tough but I'm
armed with my ideas a lot of these
people are hurting and many of them are
probably hopeless and they're sinking
into despair but I'm here to teach them
that we can turn this thing around
capitalism has destroyed the world am i
right look at this you can see there's
probably a house there but the whole
area has been be industrialized there's
just an open field see would you like to
hear more about Bernie Sanders he's also
doing a lot of these people are not home
and it's because many of them are have
died because they don't have insulin
people have to work now 24 hours a day
to afford a [ __ ] house these people
are probably working if they have a job
which they probably don't I was doing
this the other day
Elizabeth Warren sent [ __ ] goons they
jumped out of a van and they [ __ ] put
a put a pillowcase over my [ __ ] head
knocked me over that's the [ __ ]
president you want you sit [ __ ]
but I'm happy to do my part where I can
part where we can't
people have not been as receptive as I'd
Hub